Berge, so weit die Augen sehen können,
malerische Täler und Dörfer
– all das gibt es in den Alpen.
Für die Österreicherin Katharina Kos
bedeutet Wandern Freiheit.
Also, Wandern ist für mich irrsinnig schön,
weil diese Verbundenheit
zur Natur stattfindet.
Man bewegt sich draußen die ganze Zeit
und in Verbindung mit der Tatsache,
dass man einen Weg selber geht.
Man fährt nicht mit dem Auto,
man fährt nicht mit dem Radl,
wird nicht von Elektronik unterstützt, von
Technik, sondern man ist ganz bei sich.
Heute testet sie mit ein paar anderen den
neuen Weitwanderweg „Alpenjuwelen“.
Die Strecke verläuft von
Garmisch-Partenkirchen in Deutschland
über Österreich nach Südtirol in Italien.
Der Österreicher Georg Pawlata
hat die Route zusammengestellt.
Die „Alpenjuwelen“
sind ein Weitwanderweg
auf leichten bis maximal
mittelschweren Bergwegen
und sind als Weitwanderungen
für Einsteiger gedacht.
Erster Höhepunkt der Tour: die Zugspitze
mit knapp 3000 Metern Höhe.
Von Deutschlands höchstem Berg
genießen die Teilnehmer den Blick
auf mehr als 400 Gipfel
in Deutschland, Italien, Österreich
und der Schweiz.
Dann geht die Wanderung am Fuße
des Berges erst richtig los:
nach Ehrwald in Österreich.
Auf der ersten Tagesetappe laufen die
Wanderer achteinhalb Kilometer.
In den Bergen müssen sie sich auf
kurzfristige Wetterwechsel einstellen:
Es kann schneien, regnen oder heiß sein.
Da Georg Pawlata seit rund 40
Jahren in den Bergen unterwegs ist,
weiß er genau, welche Kleidung
Wanderer benötigen.
Ganz wichtig ist die
atmungsaktive Unterwäsche,
zum Beispiel Merino oder Kunstfaser,
etwas, was sehr schnell trocknet.
Dann eine leichte Wanderhose,
die ebenfalls bei ...,
wenn es regnen sollte,
mal schnell trocknet.
Und das Wichtigste sind die Schuhe:
Die sollten auf jeden Fall
knöchelhoch sein,
wasserabweisend zum Beispiel
mit Goretex
und eine gute Profilsohle haben.
Nächster Tag, zweite Etappe
der „Alpenjuwelen“:
Zunächst geht es mit der Almbahn
hoch auf 1.500 Meter.
Heute führt die Route durch das Gaistal.
Jetzt wird es für die Wanderer sportlich.
Da ist die gesamte Etappenlänge
fünfzehneinhalb Kilometer.
Ungefähr viereinhalb
Stunden gehen wir.
[Ich] glaub, das sollten wir
locker schaffen.
Wem das zu weit ist,
der kann sich zum nächsten Ziel
mit einem Auto bringen lassen.
Das gehört zum Konzept der Tour.
Und auch schweres Gepäck müssen die
Teilnehmer nicht selbst schleppen.
Sie benötigen nur einen leichten Rucksack,
in den folgende Dinge gehören: ...
Für den Notfall ganz unerlässlich:
ein vollständig geladenes Telefon mit
eingespeicherten Notfallnummern.
Zusätzlich sollte man mitnehmen:
eine Wanderkarte, wo die Route
drinnen eingezeichnet ist, ...
... außerdem Wasser, energiereiche Snacks,
Sonnencreme,
ein Erste-Hilfe-Set und warme Kleidung.
Die „Alpenjuwelen“ sind auf sechs
Tagesetappen verteilt.
Insgesamt ist die Strecke 76 Kilometer lang.
Da bleibt der Muskelkater nicht aus
– auch nicht bei erfahrenen
Wanderern wie Katharina Kos.
Das Anstrengendste an der
heutigen Etappe war,
als dann doch eine beträchtliche
Steigung zu bewältigen war.
Da zieht's dann halt schon mal
in den Wadeln oder in der Ferse.
Alle zwei Stunden nehmen sich
die Wanderer Zeit zum Essen.
Die Strecke führt an ausgewählten
Almhütten vorbei.
Sie servieren Speisen wie
zum Beispiel Kiachl,
eine gebackene Tiroler Spezialität, die
man deftig oder süß genießen kann.
Wandern ist gesund.
Es stärkt die Abwehrkräfte
und die Muskulatur.
Und diese Alpenüberquerung ist auch
für Kinder und Senioren machbar.
Das Grün wirkt wie Wellness
für die Seele.
Ja, schau mal, hier haben wir einen
traumhaften Blick auf die Dolomiten.
Das wäre der Schlern.
Dahinter ist dann die Rosengartengruppe,
in der Mitte drin die Vajolettürme,
und ganz im Hintergrund sehen wir schon
die Palagruppe, die schon im Trentino liegt.
Die letzte Etappe führt in den Ort
Jenesien im italienischen Südtirol.
Die Pfarrkirche St. Genesius sieht
man schon von Weitem.
Sie wurde im 16. Jahrhundert gebaut.
Einige Wanderer besuchen noch die
Stadt Bozen südlich von Jenesien.
Sie liegt auf gut 260 Metern Höhe.